(soft music)
Welcome to Drew's Love Bug with me and Garcelle
and we have some questions
from our VFS first joining us
is Natalie from Mobile, Alabama.
Natalie, are you there?
Yeah, I'm here.
Hi, Natalie
How are y'all?
Hi, Natalie, what is your question?
So me and my ex were together for 13 years
and we have three kids.
We were engaged in that engagement was broken off.
I dated on and off
and right now I'm struggling
whether we should get back together
or just co-parent as friends
because there was a lot of disappointments
in our broken engagement.
And so I'm trying to figure out what best for the kids.
(sighs off)
Garcelle, would you like to go first?
Okay.
Um, I think it's great
when families feel that they can get back together
and put their differences aside and work on it.
My concern is...
And listen, I've gone through that in my head going,
do we try to make it work?
Do we go back?
What I was afraid of for my life that
if we went back together and it didn't work out,
that's reopening a wound
that I feel like my kids go through.
Oh, Yeah.
So you have to be really sure
that you guys can make it work.
And I would do it slowly and not tell the kids right away.
The last thing you wanna do is rehurt the kids
with another split.
Yeah
Garcelle
I completely second
and I couldn't have said it better myself.
That is absolutely it.
The concern is reopening the wound for the kids
but also giving them not only a false hope
but then in the future, having any lack of trust
that the rug might be pulled out from under them again.
Or is it me?
I'm scared of resentment being like you didn't try.
Mh!
So that's like one of my peers
is like resentment for my kids.
I like you didn't try
for us to have a family or something like that, so.
Well--
Okay. Let me just say this.
They're gonna resent you about something in life (chuckles).
Just know that.
(both laugh)
Yeah, I mean yeah, I did that
But I think also you are trying
trying us co-parenting is trying,
you're putting the kids first.
You're doing things together as a family
even though you're not living in the same house.
I mean, those are things that you can say to your kids,
dad and I are really trying
to have the best life for you guys.
And sometimes that might mean
we don't live in the same place but we love you.
I think reinforcing
that you guys are together regardless is important.
If you have unfinished business with him
though I think what Garcelle was saying is
get to know this
and finish up the business with him away from the kids.
So if it's ultimately
we're gonna get back together, it's that?
Or we're gonna take time to close this up.
So I'm as certain as I possibly can be
and to get that confidence, whatever you do
do it with him away from the kids.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I agree with drew do it.
The two of you, it's grown-up business anyways, right?
Exactly.
The kids aren't involved on that.
Um, Garcelle and Natalie, thank you.
(upbeat music)